what what this is anarchy well Gareth
welcome to my house and I brought you
here today because I wanted to show you
what people call it's a cartoon and this
one was made by problems sending so far
this one was made by what people call a
couple of Frenchie's
it's a French cartoon one one of these
guys wrote
uh-huh movie for Roman Polanski called
the tenant and that same guy was in
earnest fraught to with Werner Herzog
and the other guy was in advertising and
then he ended up working in a
psychiatric institution then he got into
animation read traditional way to get
into the cartoons in other words the
Roman Polanski association is the most
normal credit of the two unfortunately
okay so a French cartoon yep
while we go ahead and play this on Jimmy
Jimmy is not real so film I obtained ooh
the Grand Prix de festival the animation
the Mamiya the Grand Prix de Rock contra
cinematographic there crowd le prix
special do J do Festival the tropical
a farting earth production alright now I
wish I was on hallucinogens so it's just
the field of people on fart ball well so
far it's super French right yeah they
asked Argo the snails anyway here we go
it'll get good mother earth maybe we
think yeah I guess
takes a while to get in there it's quite
an establishing a silly plan so they do
all this water Sam and then you get
nothing for it this is the shittiest
farmer in the world by the way they just
got a little it takes some time
sacrebleu the drought perhaps I should
have sex with the whole of my radish I
don't think you know how farming work I
think the only thing to do to get the
turnips going is to stir it with a
little bit of penis fertilizer what I
mean he's not saying anything someone's
got to fill in the gaps I will make a
stink sure that's exactly I would make a
lettuce slingshot now what is he trying
to die yeah right what is what is his
solution he's just treating it like
Jesus I'm putting it on a cross he's
trying to figure out instead of
obviously he's trying to save on water
this is our dystopian future yes oh no
now I'm all my crops have flown away
cursey a balloon
oh here is where it gets French yeah oh
it's very French a cry for I realize the
lettuce but then what happened was my
salty tears actually made them blossom
Oh
so you should have [ __ ] watered it
that's what you have to do is get
depressed enough to cry on your crops by
the way that is the future we will have
farmers and fields trying to weep over
their their soil I hope so
now he's happy now he only has to do
that with 500 more yeah cheers well that
was good
[Music]
he's now he's using onion get it yeah
you got it right yeah yeah no it's a
thinker world's worst farmer I can't
fault him it's working oh sorry about
the human skull it's a question about
the human skull oh yeah bud bud bud bud
he he's gonna get at what cost at what
cost is the question oh you know what
farming is hard it's a lot of people
don't realize see it worked I'm having
trouble finding the moral someone's
bring it home some cash this year what a
crop bigger than the house I cried too
much no I cannot cut them down the giant
let this oh I just eaten let my guess
bachelor let us in
that's it I didn't know uh-oh we go yeah
go yeah so this is gonna get bad we have
a knot for this snails we have a turn
haven't this a turning point they have
teeth well
so yeah oh [ __ ]
so this is for sure French I would have
liked to been there for the pitch
meeting on this my guess is that was a
five minute meeting you have nobody to
blame for that accident but yourself
yeah if you hit a snail [ __ ] you know oh
okay so the snails have killed a lot of
people from what I understand yeah sure
sure
anyway France is normal hey boss what do
we do personally come the sanella come
for all of us I kind of well he's really
working the in-and-out action on those
tellers or feelers out there
tentacles they're not tentacles antennae
I don't know zone I've been telling it
call them tails slimy face fingers
anyway in the village where everyone's
just [ __ ] and not enjoying their
worrying about snails finally some
[ __ ] look at you penis is that the
man we do what the fatality deserves
this moment I am Oh what I did not
expect it it woo
oh he's a drummer I love drum errors
that's not a drummer dude yes those are
drum sticks oh she doesn't see them
she's just independently changed now
she's I think she's getting ready for
summer that's on the bed that we're just
not having that person you know I never
thought I'd have a comfortable space to
talk about how I wanted to watch a snail
[ __ ] a woman here we are
Oh No yeah she went into your going past
the velvet rope doing a closure there
that's not hurt so he had over here
kidnapping all the women he had two
issues and who I'm in the guy who made
this oh let's chat that's how you get
ladies into your snail hole these terms
need to get adjusted immediately anyway
that's what's going on in this town I'm
not sure I understand what's going on
nobody does even think I made it didn't
know what it look at that guy
I want that guy to be snail eaten what
what this is anarchy oh this is when
Trump was there she jumps in front of
his car he come on it's survival of the
fittest get rid of this look if you
can't I run a snail [ __ ] ah I mean the
snails are not [ __ ] around I'm Millie
as French don't be
[Music]
[Applause]
how long can it go on simple Lord
Frenchman now I'm the guy who questions
lettuce and ruins yours this is about
war man is it yeah I'm having trouble
finding reaction how do you not see it
destruction of the cities everybody wait
get on one of their backs these guys
like each other
the French snail whoa the Eiffel Tower
Jesus the pentagram
that's what snails doing they have
nothing else to do once they've killed
all the humans what they cheer lead what
is going on
snail times what's going on
building their own city angry at France
anyway this guy needs to stop being a
farmer what what have we walked away
with from watching us well we know that
war kills people are you talking about
dude
we know this guy we just did this [ __ ]
carrots so it's gonna be different right
I'm really hoping we don't follow a
carrot thread what can go wrong with
this is like if black mirrors suck oh my
god is it a cliffhanger here we go
that's amazing that's amazing I like the
ending I was so on board till the ending
part to roll the carrots Johnny now part
dude no bunny
just insane that reminds me of like a
cartoon like my mother would try to show
me when I was a kid and I would be like
get out of here what are you doing was
she was she trying to make you psychotic
no just English she'd be like you like
this it's about to wolf that sings and
I'm gonna get this out of here here's
one about snails then that's an out of
going for war as perverted snails
[Music]